حبيبي يابا حبيبي يابا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
يابك احنا عمال غلابه والله وعمال المشتد
ما عرفناش وين نروح قعدنا في زاويه انا
وخمس السادس ات الشرطه دون على السجن
بعدين على السجن بعدين على السجن تتسيون
وبعدين
هاتكه كلبشات في الادين كلبشات في الرجلين
في ناس
انضرب اخذ كل حاجه خس 5500 شيكل كان معاي
والجوال والمرمر والهويه وكرتي الباص تبع
الركيبه كله
اخذوه يرض عل
[موسيقى]
يا كل ماشوف صورته كنت
اعيط والله يا عم كنا في حاله رعب رعب
كبير مش شويه رعب رعب من ساعه ما اخذتني
الشرطه لغايه ما فركونا هنا واحنا في ر
الي الي من 14 الشهر في السجن حصب الجنون
اقسم بالله الناس انهدت بتعرف بدلوا على
ابسط شيء صاروا في السجن نفسيه مضغوطه
مضغوطه بشكل مش
[موسيقى]
طبيعي الله يوقفها الحرب المجنونه هذ حرب
مجنونه دمار شامل هذه هذه دمار شامل لكل
الشعب حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل وبس حسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل احنا بدنا نعيش بدنا
نعيش بدنا نعيش بدنا نعيش زي بقيه
[موسيقى]
الشع